Hein?! Euh j'm'en occupe !
Oh putain...
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait encore là ?
Je sais pas je me souviens juste de...
...j'sais pas !
C'est quoi cette voix là?
Ouais j'sais pas j'ai dû trop gueuler.
Ah mon dieu !
Je me souviens juste du début quoi !
Salut mec !
Salut les gars !
Bah rentrez, entrez hein, on va se mettre bien !
Elles arrivent quand les biatchs là ?
Oh y a Robin qui devrait pas tarder là
Ah il vient ?
Euh moins fort les gars
Eh, tu fais quoi là ?
Je fais pipi !
Eh y en a qui veulent aller aux cabinets là !
Ouais hein !
T'es vraiment dégueulasse quand tu fais ça !
Mais ferme ta gueule !
Ah! Ça doit être Flash !
Saaaaalut les pédés !
Énorme !
Après c'est le Black-Out !
Si ça se trouve c'est pas nous qui avons fait ça ! On sait pas hein !
Oh les mecs on m'a péta mon cœur. Hahahahah.....
[gémissements]
Oh dur...
Ah ! Charles !
Euh, tu peux checker nos souvenirs
parce que c'est flou en fait...
Ok je fais ça !
Non! Là tu n'arriveras à rien du tout Ahhh!
Allez là c'est bon ! Roh...
Euh on peut mettre moins fort la musique les gars ?
Woh woh woh les gars les gars les gars...
Un grand pouvoir implique...
...de niquer sa raaaace !
Aah aah qu'est-ce que t'as ?!
Ah c'est marrant mais en fait non parce que je peux en mourir de ça
Non s'il vous plait les gars
Baisser un peu parce que là ma proprio elle va gueuler et tout donc euh...
Ouais ouais grave !
Eh mec niveau son chuis au max, t'as pas un truc pour booster ?
J'sais pas t'as qu'à mettre ta batterie là !
Oh ouais graaave !
Snoop dogg !
Ahhhh, arrêtez !
A moi !
Moi moi moi !
Woaaaw !
Elle est pas mortelle cette soirée ?!
C'est pas une soirée. C'est un sketch Suricate.
Ouais énorme !
Ca va man ?
Wooo !
Et là ça t'énerve ?
Ça t'énerve là quand je fais ça ?
J'ai dit moins fort la MUSIIIIQUE !
Oooh meeerde !
Que s'est-il passé exactement ? Qui est derrière tout ça ?
Ah ben ça c'est un coup du Joker. C'est le Joker.
Calme toi Hulk on va ranger !
Hé Hulk, on voit ta teub !
Ooh je me suis coupé !
Lex Luthor, le Bouffon Vert, Magneto
Enfin tous les connards, c'est eux qui ont fait ça...
Attends, attends, attends. Viens on baise !
Ah les salauds. Les salauds, les salauds.
Les salauds, les salauds, les salauds ! Ah ah !
Que signifie ce symbole sur la lune ?
Encore une énigme ?
Ouiiii oui oui c'est une énigme
On est... Enfin on va taffer dessus
On nettoie là un peu la ville
Mais on est... hein, on va s'en occuper !
Oh il a dessiné une teub !
Oui madame Suzanne. Oui. Je sais mais c'est la dernière fois promis.
Non mais je sais que l'état des lieux c'est demain, je sais. Mais là je...
...suis à l'étranger en fait. Ben encore une fois je suis désolé hein.
Allô ?